[Music]
legend tells of a lost species a link
between man and beast for centuries he's
lived in hiding but at long last he's
reaching out and ready to be found
[Music]
excuse me hi you can speak yes and I
write as well my penmanship isn't great
but you know opposable thumbs and that
fingers you know
meet mr. Ling
you know like missing link ah wait I
don't get it I'll treat her of enormous
stature
eight feet tall six hundred and fifty
pounds like you know six hundred thirty
pounds no it's it's the hair that makes
me look heavier I think it's it's a
little deceptive it to be frustrating
these are links to our past
Oh of connection to our present oh oh
and our bridge to the future oh wait a
second I said oh like I knew what you
were talking about but I don't well I'm
on that this spring on the other side of
the world are my cousins you take me
there I know the secret ways to the
mountains
is it hard to hear the old names crack
over the week doh oh that's better
the search for his kind I'll bring that
proof of the greatest discovery of the
century will become an adventure
of mythical proportions quick quick
quick someone should give her the kiss
of life you're the man for the job
how's my breath here's the missing link
from me out of the pit I think you might
be a little too heavy nonsense now give
it all you've got
oh it's hard to know whose fault that
was let's do it again
[Music]